yearbooks have a habit of haunting
politicians this 2001 photo of Justin
Trudeau in brownface is no different
clearly rattled the Canadian Prime
Minister at pains to apologize in 2001
when I was a teacher in Vancouver I
attended an end-of-year gala where the
theme was Arabian Nights anyway dressed
up in Aladdin costume and put makeup on
it was something that I didn't think was
racist at the time but now I recognize
it was something racist to do and I am
deeply sorry
the scandal fuel to the fire of Canada's
election campaign wearing brown face is
an act of open mockery and racism it was
just as racist in 2001 as it is in 2019
what Canadians saw this evening is
someone with a complete lack of judgment
and integrity and someone who's not fit
to govern this country
Trudeau launched his reelection bid last
week just as reports emerged that police
are investigating claims he had
corruption charges dropped against an
engineering company but for someone who
has me political he out of his support
for multiculturalism this could be more
damaging what's troubling I mean it's
really it's insulting
anytime we hear examples of brown face
or black face saying it's really it's
it's it's making a mockery of someone
for what they live and what the relived
experiences are I think he needs an
answer for it he's got to answer the
question why he did that perhaps more
than the charge of racism this image
will lead to questions of authenticity
and whether Justin Trudeau is indeed the
poster boy of liberalism that he claims
to be from Iran this I'm joined by GW
reporter Peter Dahl so Peter this
certainly doesn't look good for anyone
but definitely not Justin Trudeau who is
a major Western leader in the middle of
a campaign
yeah I think that's putting it mildly
I mean really this is just the latest
chapter and what appears to be a pretty
dramatic fall from grace for Justin
Trudeau remember just four years ago he
wrote into office on on this rainbow of
optimism right he was being billed as a
Canadian Obama he had developed almost a
cult following thanks to you know his
model good looks and viral photos of him
and gravity-defying yoga poses and it
really made him the heartthrob of people
around the world you know female ant
male and from many he was seen as the
beginning of a new era in Canadian
politics he ran on a very liberal agenda
in his cabinet was the most diverse and
Canadian history unlike many of his
predecessors he actively sought to make
amends for Canada's colonial sense and
so I think all this taken together like
it's the image stands in such stark
contrast to the photo that just emerged
that many voters are now wondering
what's all of that just an act
absolutely so Brown and blackface has a
long rather derogatory history for those
who don't know what is so offensive
about it well it was born out of racism
it became a centerpiece of white
American popular culture in the mid to
late 19th century actors would paint
their face blacken and you know these
big bright red lips and perform these
incredibly demeaning caricatures of
black people painting them as basically
subhuman let me show you what I'm
talking about
[Music]
and so this tradition continued well
into the 20th century
but it starts like Judy Garland we see
here portraying black people as you know
people minded gullible shuckin and jivin
jokes and it really was a way to keep
black people in their place make sure to
show them as unfit for equal treatment
and you know this history has been well
documented and the tradition needs to be
buried
and yet we see blackface continuing to
pop up here and there still today yeah
it really continues to Honda's right and
especially in the US where similar
scandals have emerged just in recent
months or weeks even with white people
in power
just last month we saw the Governor of
Alabama KIV who was forced to apologize
after it was revealed that she had worn
blackface in college this came after
Virginia Governor Ralph Northam was
almost forced to step down after photo
vez of his medical school yearbook
showed him in blackface and it's not
just politicians to see right here
fashion label Gucci had to pull this
wedding for his collection fallen
complaints that it resembled a blackface
yes so fashionable so now the flip side
of the argument is these things happen
many decades ago there were students
when this happened is it fair to hold
these politicians to account now I
absolutely think it is especially in the
case of Trudeau he was born in the 70s
he is 47 today he was not a product of
the segregationist 50s and 60s the way
friends and I've urine or Northam were
right he came of age when Rodney King
was beaten to a pulp in LA he knows what
racism looks like and so when he decided
to wear that brown face as a 29 year old
teacher at that we had already entered
the 21st century to say that he didn't
consider it racist at the time it's
either frankly ignorant or disingenuous
and I'm not sure which is worse not if
not a great excuse all right Peter doll
for us thank you so much thank you